E aí
[Música]
é uma cinza é uma curva cujo jornada é o
centro médico Duarte ciclo cujo raio é
igual a fita bem no a vizinhos que
representa a curva prega consegue a
em cima da origem desta palavra estão
significado de picada marca feita com um
ferro que sinal ou tatuagem da Medicina
indica assinou resistente ou
característica de uma certa doença na
gíria do do nosso dia a dia indica a
prestação negativa perante um certo
grupo característica ou comportamento
estado bastante organizado na nossa
sociedade
e o nosso cavalo social aumentar quem
não somos ao longo a sensibilidade se o
favor de sou feio mas formado na São
vídeos é sempre pegava esses padrões
pré-estabelecidos o Peter não tem mais
um ter escrever acordar muito grave
mesmo batalhas também de pentear as
carregadas que abraçados e assim
aceitavelmente gente bastante segurança
certo no entanto claramente já aprendi a
lidar com isso aqui isso não quer dizer
que já estão representativas da
profissão de idade é por exemplo como eu
e a minhas fotografia dicas estou sempre
ouvir os clássicos pela esta alimentar
as uma pessoa amada da sua fisiologia
certo
a festa de seguranças foram alimentadas
com frequência podem mesmo de fumar
também as proporções dos canhões
instalar-se em forma de medo tanto
individualmente quanto a nossa jornada
em conjunto recusando os a ter uma
atitude passiva para disto são tem
confirmadas por natureza e fazemos
questão que esse valor ante não está das
quando se propósito é 2018 com 21 22
anos tivemos uma ideia que mudou nossa
vida com a transação conhecimento do
Meio Académico e problemas dos clientes
criamos assaltante a nevar com o pode
desenvolver soluções para seu digital e
nos primeiros meses foi precisamente
para combater os dias hoje em dia
Trabalhamos também para a gestão E
permitir a sua mãe estava de uma forma
mais abrangente corrido a verificação e
com base na evidência nomeadamente do
reconhecimento Nacional através de
padrões fisiológicos e comportamentais a
ciência na verdade está num só na parte
tudo para fazeres como se tudo o que nos
rodeia deves Consegues aplicados a sua
compreensão medição e avaliação
e para muitos problemas de saúde mental
são sinónimo de invalidez ou
incapacidade e não psicólogo que quer
dizer que se ama looking a uma
desvalorização Global dos nossos
sentimentos e Emoções já todos ouvimos
um tem cala e já passa no momento da
definição e provavelmente já tivemos
mesmo dos dois lados quem recebe e de
quem diz eu não sinto que tu sentes nem
consigo pelo e portanto a tendência
humana é para minimizar a sua
importância antes não teria que agora
vivemos cerca de novecentos e setenta
milhões de pessoas em todo o mundo
sofriam de um distúrbio de saúde mental
agora apesar dos efeitos da pandemia não
serem ainda completamente conhecidos os
estudos reportam que mais de Metade das
pessoas que sofreram algum Impacto
psicológico nove em cada dez pessoas com
distúrbios de saúde mental diagnosticado
reportam que a discriminação e o sistema
tem um elevado Impacto sobre o seu dia a
dia segunda mental Health foundation
em outras condições de longa duração ou
incapacidades esta mesma que mais inibe
é empregabilidade não está marca d'água
nos o cérebro Estava sempre tudo pelo
móvel obtenção aguentado tudo nosso
corpo fazer a base de ligações
genealógicas igualdades forma mais que
assim como base fisiológica em tudo o
que acontece é que ele faz é possível a
compreender sua causa e a partir em
avaliar possíveis medidas a tomar um
O que significa que o básica essa mais
tempo tecnológica na verdade você deve
alguma para fazer a devida mente isso
que ela era o escreve dentro da gente no
dia a dia e no entanto quando ultrapassa
determinado patamar pode faço a tornar
disfuncional negativa do nosso
funcionamento podemos assumir diferentes
formas entre as quais as vias mas
independentemente da sua forma otimo ela
manifesta-se nosso corpo seja através de
seguros pelo menos respiração ou
problemas de estômago e pode mesmo
existe por exemplo em estados e levará a
cidade que não ritmo cardíaco aumenta e
o intervalo entre batimentos cardíacos
diminuem significativamente resolveram
estado Alegre que se equipara a nossa
atenção que temos calça vestido preto
sempre morte
e Isto pode ser quantificado através de
um parâmetro que se chama variabilidade
do Ritmo cardíaco em casos de ansiedade
esta variabilidade diminuir afeta as
duas assim a nossa capacidade de reação
e com quem são internados nos hospitais
provinciais exaustão portanto ao
contrário do que se pensa apesar de
muitos variável tudo isto é real
tangível e tem consequências se
fortíssimos uma perna e então biblioteca
tudo volta ao normal certo no caso da
Saúde Mental sofria exatamente o mesmo
poderíamos deixar de agir como se não
fosse
e parece lá é alguém para fazer todo e a
gente vai empreendedor ele cima
desembarque mas não importa o nosso
canal Mas você também consigo expressa
acela é visão que esse lado tem o que é
o empreendedorismo leve do que a gente
ou quando é que pode publicar as
empresas também teve a criar um curso
agora ela não vai sentir seguro viagem
convívio mas trabalho viu e o plástico
acha que podem não é Fazer o quê
e não quer dizer empreendedor na verdade
é muito mais do que ser empresário é um
é mais um estado de espírito um estado
de constante inquietação na verdade é
muito semelhante ao processo de
engenharia identificar o problema e
rejeitar uma solução que coladas
limitações das já existentes para nós
ser empreendedor é querer fazer
acontecer é não nos conformamos com a
situação só porque assim que ele é que
normalmente encarada é querer
impulsionar a mudança olhos para o fim
de ele te convidar todos nós certo mas
sabiam quando elas o pela primeira vez o
Mickey Mouse foi gerado pela leitora
pelo simples fato da vida que base pode
né que a cidade dos ratos podem ir em
que se grava o desempenho EA treino
clicar em pouco né Sempre provavelmente
não ela é uma bioquímica um garoto que
durante anos estudou os mecanismos
baseados em RH e os seus projetos foram
constantemente disponibilizados entre as
duas tentativas de financiamento sido
rejeitadas hoje é dia
a tua mãe e seu trabalho está na base da
vacina contra o 2019 moral da história
ser empreendedor é você tá com os
parentes fazem parte da jornada e que
são nossa maior fonte de aprendizagem é
que tá na visão e não desistir não há
bem que sempre dure nem mal que nunca
teria de fazer diferente se tivesse
parado ou não tivesse tivesse ainda para
ouvir neste os alimentos assim
Tu viu que esta tendência enquanto motor
para a mudança que nos falamos é mesmo
aos que se treinar o nosso lobo frontal
definir e gêneros nossos objetivos no
diariamente o córtex pré-frontal é
responsável pelo nosso foco gestão da
memória de curto prazo e força de
vontade no fundo é um motor da nossa
resiliência e perseverança no entanto as
estruturas cerebrais responsáveis pelo
nosso compromisso e planeamento da
mudança não comunicam diretamente com as
estruturas responsáveis pelo controlo
dos nossos hábitos e da espera conseguir
as espaço e vice uma bandeira
neurológica quase constante entre os
passos da Sérvia responsáveis pela
informação mais recente o córtex
pré-frontal e a mais antiga o sistema
límbico O primeiro é capaz de usar a
tarefa mas não automaticamente precisa
ser estimulado ao passo que segundo é
capaz de fazer isto conscientemente
eu quero ver que eu tinha novamente
igual proposto por não serve a liberdade
de um termina um neurotransmissor
responsável pelo Circuito das novas
recompensa fazermos sentir fisicamente
bem é para isso que a visão consciente
de uma jornada é tão a ficar esperando o
mesmo também diabetes como por exemplo
estudar assim o segredo das experiências
tem utilizarmos a dopamina e nosso favor
mas pouco em primeiro lugar ser
consistentes mesmo quando nos apetece
começando a 5S muito restaurante as
costas transformar ideias complexas
aquelas mais simples e por último para
tornar cada pequena Vitória com quem nos
rodeia ao com um ponto anterior cada
reforço positivo levar a uma maior
manifestação de sua família aumentando
então o sentimento de perder e
autorrealização que também estava sempre
em dia e mostrar mais do que uma as
pessoas ouvir a caminhar para
identificar Mas uma coisa é certa é
muito mais do que ele faz para comer
tudo com o resultado é possível
trabalhar e também provar ao foi que
seja por uma
um pouco mas a minha Histórica de
presente escravos quando tudo ao
empreendedor que estava se cadastra
Minas para entrar na sala não podem
sorrir quem é o programa este vocês o
que se não posso dizer isto que estão
mulheres na sala o que merda
é a primeira mulher Sim ela foi Ketlin
branco em 1982 E aí 2021 ainda estamos
neste estado sabia que da Europa apenas
trinta por cento de todos os fundadores
de empresas são mulheres e em Portugal
apenas de Seis por cento das mulheres
auxílios e sabiam que não queres dizer
não a trabalhar mais 54 vezes o que um
homem para obter um rendimento durante
como se não bastasse no que toca a
previsão de investimentos estudos que
mostram que os homens têm oitenta e Seis
por cento maior probabilidade de
angariar investimentos de risco do
colheres no entanto os estudos também
demonstram que estão acostumados por
mulheres têm um desempenho ms63 por
cento melhor do que se trata mas
fundadas exclusivamente por homens para
aumentar realmente sentido toda esta
disparidade chefe o que está Nas
urgências em primeiro lugar a percebe o
que é um homem Veste uma mulher a
questão de liderança ele é dos
corretores ela era Nacional ele é
honesto é legal
e também é esse aqui é levantou Ele é
especialista ela é exibicionista ele é
confiar descontrair desleixada queria
lhe ver a força aguenta para ela quiser
a dúvida disso é uma mulher
o Lucas princípio esta disparidade tão
diferente de homens como de outras
mulheres mas nem sempre nos damos conta
aliás muitas vezes acontece o mesmo sem
pensar duas vezes antes de quem julga
com quem és legal é o que também foi
usado numa sociedade que acontece mesmo
De forma inconsciente Esta é a definição
do estereótipo
E lembra-se quando é que vai cantar em
conjunto E para o tempo são regiões do
cérebro que tomar um papel Central em
funções como a aprendizagem EA memória
obtenção do comportamento social estão
em constante desenvolvimento até a fase
adulta conhecido pela abreviação
personalidade e tomar uma decisão a um
princípio que ilustra muito bem o que
acontece a quantidade formação do
esteriótipo o princípio de reto são os
parece guerra vai acontecer e é
precisamente isso que acontece para ter
tido O que as bem conhecidas feitas
cultural uma ligação mental gerada antes
era meu pau enorme houve sempre uma
ligação Natal traga a menina que
assistimos vai sentindo a ligação vai
também estão presentes assim quando você
tem que usar ativado toda a cadeia de
Reginópolis associadas esse estímulo
cultural vai ser desencadeada ativar
desligar os neurônios e produzindo um
determinado comportamento quando somos
crianças o meu cérebro apanha tudo o que
nos rodeia nomeadamente a cultura de
rosa e do azul influenciando assim a
forma como pensam
é importante desde cedo as diferentes
expectativas impostas a rapazes e as
raparigas vão influenciar a nossa
autoconfiança e capacidade de arriscar
enviesada sim as diferentes trajetórias
profissionais e as nossas definições de
sucesso
um convite a cultura é capaz de moldar a
nossa biologia de factos estão fora de
nosso controle de uma exposição a estes
estereótipos mas para a geralmente
sentido uma sociedade para levar o homem
à nossa vai passar até não teríamos
Espaço da Beleza estar integrantes não é
o gênio que faz alguém mais pra parte
sensível a gente não é sentir homem mas
é de mulher o mundo é binário somos
todos pessoas estão nas nossas mãos
quebrar cada uma destas ideias
pré-concebidas onde a pena é pesado o
nosso cérebro que muda criamos novas
ligações de legais tanto na nossa
infância como ao longo de toda a vida
como vimos a tendência de trás das
paredes e diz-nos que o grau se mas
vamos usar as três ingredientes
principais em primeiro lugar tomada de
consciência da sua presença é
fundamental reconhecer que só sei que
não dá 100 EA sua relação não assim tão
paradoxal com os a virei poder não
consegui misturar aquilo que não consigo
sentir e portanto conhecimento EA
informação são fundamentais para
reconhecermos onde estamos
nós não temos também tá dizendo bons
como nos maus momentos em segundo
motivação própria são dessa crença com a
força de vontade e com certeza de que
haverá sempre uma descarga da primeira
virada China escada essa que pode pagar
bastante simples será utilizada nas rede
as pessoas com quem gostamos apresentar
implorar vitórias bem como passar
derrotas esterilizar e valorizar
aspectos positivos ou comunicar para
esclarecer mal-entendidos no fundo
alimentarmos a nossa resiliência com
quem está sempre da mesma frequência e
por fim o tempo para a instalação da
mudança à semelhança dos neurônios que
com força da repetição um único neurônio
tem capacidade de gerar uma cadeia de
gás também uma pessoa apenas tem a
capacidade de gerar uma mudança do mundo
começaram por se seguinte quem está à
distância de um braço que ao fazer o
mesmo permitir ao em última instância
abraçar o mundo para algo verão de viver
os adeptos estarão ativos a cultura
Olá tudo certinho por variáveis
Independentes dias horas meses anos e
variáveis dependentes mais produtivas
positivas ou negativas e Presidente
apresentadas as abscissas vai apresentar
então alguns Episódios não precisamos
confrontar exatamente por exemplo o
início da jornada de levar foi
encorajado com bastante entusiasmo
rapidamente se transformou numa forma de
provar são tantos por descrença ou
preocupação Claro que isto nos fez
turnês estão vindo ao terminar os nossos
estudos no entanto acreditamos mais
oportunidades e assim conseguimos
conciliar anos quando começava a
realizar testes clínicos veio ambientes
fez parar por tempo indeterminado mas
não vamos ao nosso o mundo inteiro po.to
sofreu esta mudança de paradigma mas a
sentimos aproveitar esta pausa forçada
para também nós não nos reinventarmos e
conseguimos então alterar a forma como
entregamos saúde e
e assim acho que eu vou passar o fizer
ela e pensa não existe um desses altos e
baixos na nossa jornada dos essa outra
passe nos tinham superação quase certeza
que assistiram sentimentos bons e menos
mal e que estamos que eu faço que
acabamos aquelas as mangas e agir para
que possamos ver não é
E aí
[Música]
G1
E aí
[Aplausos]